it means that people actually want the
thing that you're selling which believe
it or not a lot of people sell stuff
that people do not want crazy i know
in this video i'm going to break down
why all of these mass market biz ah
businesses and uh consumer product
businesses plateau and so if this is you
then listen up and so uh this actually
stemmed from a conversation that i had
uh with a big uh business opportunity
business owner who's doing you know 50
60 million a year and you know they were
reaching a plateau where their their
margins were paper thin and so i wanted
to break down uh the reasons why the way
a mistake that you can avoid that took
me a very long time to figure out and a
lot of pain and so if right now you are
in one of these businesses that sells to
a consumer products alright so mass
market or b business opportunity or c
even uh services to mass market then
this video is for you all right and i'm
going to show you how you can avoid a
mistake that you won't know that you
made until it's too late alright if you
don't know hi my name is alex from
mozzie i own acquisition.com it's a
portfolio of companies that over 100
million dollars a year i have nothing to
sell you make these videos because i
want you to get to 3 million a year so i
can partner with you that's why all
right but if you're not there then i
make these videos just because i want
you to be rich af all right so let's
walk through a logical outline of what
happens in a business all right so zero
to six figures all right so zero to 100k
you sell something to someone that's
what you have to do in order to get to
100k and usually it is unreliable all
right so you have unreliable acquisition
and usually from different channels
because you don't know what you're doing
all right and that's usually what it is
all right so it's unreliable acquisition
but you are selling something to someone
now 100k to 1 million you create a
reliable and usually a single reliable
acquisition channel which means you pick
one channel one product one avatar all
right and you sell that thing that's all
you do and if you do it reliably you can
get to seven figures that is what
happens here now what i'm about to show
you is the mistake that most people make
all right at this point
we have what i would call pmf or product
market fit it means that people actually
want the thing that you're selling which
believe it or not a lot of people sell
stuff that people do not want crazy i
know all right so we have product market
fit now this is the point where people
mess stuff up because what happens is
they say hey i did this thing so if i do
more of that thing that is how i will
grow this business and the answer is yes
and also no and here's why if you do
more of what you do there are three
variables that are logical eventualities
that will occur in the business that
will eventually rob you of your margins
and so if this actually worked then you
usually are profitable right and so you
were most profitable in the beginning of
the business why because you usually had
to figure something out and you usually
have very low overhead less
infrastructure cost etc in the beginning
right now in a physical products
business specifically you do have some
economies of scale that happens when you
buy more stuff but those are diminishing
meaning you know the first two increases
in orders of magnitude of purchase is
where you get the vast majority of your
savings and then after that it's razor
thin in terms of how much uh savings
you're going to be able to have uh from
scale all right from increasing the
quantity that you purchase all right so
you're usually profitable in the
beginning and you're growing cool makes
sense now here's the thing these are the
three eventualities that happen in every
business that's mass market all right
number one is that cpms go up over time
all right they go up over time that
should make sense advertising today is
more expensive than it was yesterday and
more expensive than it was 10 years ago
right cost per impressions go up that is
an eventuality that is a lot will happen
over time number two is that you will
have to go to colder and colder
audiences which means as you scale the
conversion rate that you have on these
audiences will go down right if you had
that one channel that you were doing if
you go deeper on that channel you go to
lesser or lesser likelihood audiences of
people who are going to purchase right
this is a function of scale and so you
think about it like conversion goes down
as you scale that makes sense now the
reason that a business can scale is
because they make so much money on the
on the smaller audience that when they
go to a larger audience they still make
enough money to justify doing it but it
is a logical eventuality at some point
you'll reach a cold enough audience that
they will not buy all right and then the
third piece is that as you scale
business costs of infrastructure go up
all right which means that you have
higher fixed costs in the business which
means your margins in a railway can't
compress all right so these three things
are eventualities these are logical
outcomes that happen as you scale as the
business progresses and does more volume
all right and so if we have these three
things then what happens is let's say
this is our our line of of top line and
let's say this is our margin line
is that this starts to compress right
here and so we start making less and
less money over time even if our revenue
is going up right this margin
still starts to compress and we start to
get razor thin why because of these
three eventualities right these always
happen in every business so then you're
like okay alex that sounds like doom and
gloom then how do i combat that well
it's understanding sequence all right
and so if up to this point you said okay
i made a million dollars or making two
million dollars a year or whatever
selling uh mass market services mass
market products you're selling to
everybody you're selling to a big big
big demo all right so this is where
beauty this is where uh business
opportunity this is where investment
opportunity this is where um weight loss
uh relationship coaching big mass market
things right these are huge industries
okay and so how do we combat it we have
to have an equally strong thing that is
going in the other direction that is
decreasing our cost of acquisition and
increasing our gross profits all right
now how do we do that do that through
getting the invisible hand to work for
us which is warm word of mouth all right
now before you before you look away
because this is important this is the
invisible hand and the reason this is so
important is that as you scale right if
we're in this little you know example
over here and we go you know uh 1
million to 10 million right and the
margin goes from you know 40 to 30 and
we go 10 to 30 million we go from 30
percent to sorry from 20 to 10 margins
right and this margin keeps compressing
the thing is is that we need a
acquisition channel that doesn't behave
in these three ways how word of mouth is
quadratic in nature meaning one person
tells two two people tell four four
people tell eight and so we have far
more leverage on the acquisition of one
customer and this process right here is
what will drive down your cost of
acquisition over time at scale even if
you're reaching more people less
efficiently than you were in the
beginning which makes sense of course
you'd be less efficient at the beginning
um less efficient at scales you are in
the beginning now you might say well our
media department's better our buyings
are better our advertising is better and
sure all those things happen but these
three things are absolutes cost
impressions will go up you will market
to colder audiences who are less likely
to buy your thing and the cost of
infrastructure will increase those are
eventualities all right and so we have
to and this is the piece that everyone
misses you have to pause when you're in
that one three maybe five million dollar
pre-year range you have to pause to do
something entirely different and you
have to stop doing the thing that got
you there because continuing down that
path will eventually lead to a point
where you have lots of revenue and
basically no margin and then you will
have a hiccup you will have a mistake or
you'll have something that happens and
it will blow your business off its
course and all of a sudden you'll go
from feeling like you're on the top of
the world driving all this cash flow
driving all this revenue to being like
holy [ __ ] we're negative and we're paper
thin and i don't know what to do and you
feel like you have to keep selling just
to pay payroll but there's basically no
margin left and then you basically have
created a massive non-profit that you're
liable for right and if i'm talking to
somebody you know who you are you're
listening and you know exactly what i'm
talking about right now all right and
you and this is the eventuality that
happens unless you stop and you fix this
which makes it feel like you're doing
something out of sequence but you're
actually doing it in the right way to do
which is why you have to go slow to go
fast sometimes okay so onwards what we
have to look at is how can we improve
the customer experience right the
customer experience how can we create a
customer success team or director who
can start tracking things like time to
value like how quickly can someone you
know achieve this value what are mps
scores what are our customer health
scores what are the things that are
going to drive the one thing that
matters most which is referrals because
what happens is that most people either
have neutral or negative word of mouth
all right and so here's a way that you
know if you have negative word of mouth
negative word of mouth is when your cost
of acquisition increases at a faster
rate than the cost per impression
increases okay so if the cost per
impression is up 10 and you're up 40 it
means that you have that quadratic that
beast that i was showing earlier that
does this whatever you have that beast
but that invisible hand is now
compressing your business people who
would otherwise would have purchased see
your ads see your marketing and say oh i
actually heard something bad about that
and then boom they don't buy and not
only that the negative ones tell 10
times more people than the positive
experience one which is why it's so hard
to build a wonderful business because
it's so hard to have to be so good that
you counteract the 10 times word of
mouth that happens with a negative
experience i know this is crazy it makes
it feel makes business feel hopeless but
there is hope because if we do this in
the right sequence and we say we're
going to pay attention to things that
matter most because we're thinking about
10 years not 10 days from now we know
that these three things are going to be
the inevitable things that eat our
business and eat our margins and so we
have to combat that by pausing
increasing our integrity about the
products that we're selling right so
that we can drive the thing that will be
our our our guard our shield against
this it will be the invisible hand
fighting the negative invisible hand and
increasing it because all of a sudden
people heard something and then they see
your ad say oh i wouldn't normally have
bought it but i did hear something about
this and then they purchased and all of
a sudden what happens is holder markets
become warmer markets as a result of the
word of mouth all right and so that is
how you can use this thing to give you
the positive invisible hand that can
combat you now some businesses at scale
what they figured out is okay they're
not shitty but they're just neutral
right and the thing is is that these
three eventualities will still happen no
matter what and so you need to turn this
negative into a positive otherwise at
scale the eventuality of this business
is it will do tons of revenue and you
will reach a point of equilibrium where
your costs and your and your cash flow
are the same and you have run a massive
nonprofit that you are 100 liable for
and that is very very very stressful and
so the only way to build the enduring
brand that can continue to scale is to
have this invisible hand in your team on
your side which means you might have to
slow down for a period to figure out
what do clients really want what is the
job that they hired our products or
services to truly solve and how can we
figure out a way to truly surprise and
delight them in a way that they did not
expect which means we want to increase
the discrepancy between expectations and
delivery all right we want the liver to
be up here and we want expectations to
be on here and the problem is that most
people who are short-term short-term
minded what they do is they say they
raise expectations in order to make the
short sale but then what happens is they
can never live up to that and so we have
a negative expectation to delivery gap
and then that is what drives the
negative word of mouth in the business
which eventually dooms them and so the
idea is how can we have modest
expectations that we can set and then
create such an amazing experience
decrease the time to value so that
people say wow this thing was so much
better than i expected you should try
this out and the easy way to show this
is have you ever had somebody pump up a
movie to you and be like hey this you
got to see this thing it's so good it's
okay and you're like oh man i can't wait
to see this thing and then you're like
okay that met expectations even though
the movie was amazing movie that met
expectations because you had amazingly
high expectations on the flip side have
you ever had an experience where
someone's like oh this is a [ __ ] movie
it's terrible blah blah blah you go in
with super low expectations and then
you're pleasantly surprised right even
though the product was the same the
expectation dramatically changed our
experience of the product service etc
right and so when we're dealing with
consumer products right we want to set
modest expectations and then create room
for us to over deliver so that we can
get this word of mouth and so what we do
is we don't trade the short-term sale at
the expense of the long-term brand and
the brand in a nutshell does two things
a brand is simply what people say about
your product behind your back that's
what a brand is it's a reputation right
and the easiest way to build your
reputation is improve the quality of
your products is to keep the promises or
more than keep the promises that you
make that is how you build the brand
that will endure and that is the thing
that can achieve scale because once you
achieve scale you also have the hidden
power pricing behind you because once
people love your products and services
if you do a 10 or 20 bump in price and
for those of you who sell mass market
b2c products these things if you don't
have a change in demand all of a sudden
double triple quadruple the profit of
your business right and you can only do
this and have premium pricing power if
you have a brand otherwise you're just
media arbitraging and you will
eventually run into this these three
evils right here check check check these
three evils right here that will
eventually eat away your margins and
destroy your business all right so this
is a cautionary tale of what not to do
and sometimes you have to go slow to go
fast to build the thing that's worth
building all right so mother nation i
love you guys keep being awesome and
i'll see you guys in the next vid bye
mozzie nation you guys are the best and
if you could do me the biggest favor of
the entire world click the like button
comment below so i can answer more of
your questions in the videos and make
sure that i'm not just making stuff out
of my head but answering the questions
you guys actually want like comment i'll
see you in the next vid